e tudo bem mas estão beleza sob a gestão
será que é a minha filha ela chamou
anita ela tem 10 anos e era tipo uma
celular para celular toca a assistência
do ano tem todo mundo aqui de celular
ela ama celular velho ela ama ficar no
tipo não há desafio está ligado a ela
pegasse a sua história com as amigas na
ópera que ela perdeu no colégio not
zappa provendo os videoclipes da katy
perry no youtube ela josé o suns
aplicativo não sei pra que serve de
putinga ela ama ela ama celular velho
quase tanto quanto o pai dela que sou eu
enquanto aqui têm celular todo mundo tem
celular
aí é quantos aqui com o celular no bolso
agora quantos aqui sentem vontade de
pegar o celular quando outra pessoa pega
o celular de alguém pega agora o ovo do
pega transição que não foi o primeiro no
bolso do outro quarto pega igual a eu
quero ver quem também não tem alguma
coisa quando uma página de status na opa
chegou em mim ele tem que chegar e meio
que achou três meses aqui tal que fica
nessa semana e assim vai
a gente pega tanto o celular a minha
filha assim que o mal vejo a cara das
pessoas mais eu conheço as pessoas pelo
curu
com isso procuro que tá todo mundo assim
sabe um dia eu conheci um amigo meu
concorrente anos a seu ver a cara dele
[ __ ] nem saber que eu sou a cada
cinco anos e só conheceu cocuruto com a
minha filha assim porque eu fico direto
também no celular
esses dias na minha filha falou pai olha
pai olha pai eu não olhei ela veio pra
trás no celular está sem pai você olhar
pra mim só ficando aqui atrás do seu
celular
que horror minha filha a gente chama
tecnologia
a gente chama robô ela roubou e quanto
menos eu olho pra ela mas ela gosta dos
robôs
isso é uma reflexão que têm que fazer
todo tempo como eu sou pai de uma menina
de 10 anos e como sou pai de uma menina
de 3 anos
ok a gente chama robô a gente chama
nossos celulares
a gente gosta de tudo que está dentro
deles talvez a minha mãe reclame que eu
não saia também do videogame talvez a
minha voz é tão logo a minha mãe que ela
não sairá pela televisão o meu bisavô
estava com um pouco ele não sairá pelo
rádio que basicamente a gente sempre
gostou de tecnologia se gostou de está
conectado com outras pessoas que está
informado e tudo mais mas eu começo a
ficar preocupado com a tecnologia quando
começa a tipo uma conta da nossa vida
tipo com cursinhos que sabem fraca de
performance batimento cardíaco que a
gente está sentindo como que a gente tá
emocionando e tipo dibo já ouviram falar
no tipo velho o time um robô que é feito
para ser nosso brother
o robô própria tá lá no haiti está
ligado e aí ele olha pra você se você
sorri ele tinha foto ele lei meio pra
você lê mensagem pra você velhos aquela
história da xuxa boneca da xuxa crescer
as unhas e matava de madrugada pra mim
eu digo velho
sabe aquele mito 20 anos 80 que o boneco
do fofão tirava a cabeça uma d'água
dentro dele e tinha um ritual satânico
assim pra mim eu digo velho o dia é do
demônio vai começar a contar uma
história sua filha anã há a matar você
anda a sua família toda está o que foi a
ninguém sabe é quem só tem um robô lhe
um tiro ali parado e tem outros robôs
que atendem loja velho que mostra com
ele o produto assim ele te leva no
corredor tal então eu não sou produto a
beleza
pra mim ele vai te levar lá pro fim da
loja em seu olhar de tipos cadáver assim
de você mãe o que é isso estava o robô
vai matar você tá ligado humano e tem
essa teoria não sei se estou ligado na
na teoria do burnout é daqui que é a
cada 18 meses
o chip dobra de processamento de
capacidade de processamento e aí tem
essa idéia é que daqui a dez anos essa
teoria estiver certa em 2025 um chip vai
ter a capacidade de um cérebro humano um
chip vai ter a capacidade de um cérebro
humano ou seja um hip vai poder fazer
outro gente tiver um cérebro humano fez
um chip um chip vai fazer um outro chip
talvez um chip melhor velho e talvez
faça um chip que é o dobro daquele chip
depois de um tempo depois de 18 meses os
tipos vão ser melhores que os humanos e
os tipos vão fazer chips e os humanos
vão ficar obsoleto
e essa é no nosso sempre foi nosso
principal medo né
os robôs vão dominar o mundo e pra mim
essa é a melhor notícia do mundo
essa é a melhor coisa e poderia nos
acontecer nos robô dominar o mundo
primeiro nosso maior medo de robô
dominar o mundo é mesmo que a tecnologia
sair do controle a gente sempre vê
tecnologia sim mas mesmo vencendo o
controle não vou pegar esse avião vai
cair no carro não sei se estou ligado na
virada do século quando inventaram um
carro lá em 1900 e alguma coisa é tinha
a aas intimou quilometragem máxima pra
casa era 4 milhas por hora vai ter aqui
na frente de um carro uma pessoa a
regular com uma bandeirinha vermelhinha
dizendo bem o carro aí vem o avaí se
tinham medo da tecnologia o carro que é
uma merda seja o de um carro sem exceção
todos hips né como uma coisa e tudo mais
a parada seguinte mano carro pode ser
ruim mas é bom que exista mas a cor a
minha a minha relação com tecnologia
essa verba pode ser ruim mas é bom que
existe tem uma opção se a mulher estiver
grávida tem um filho agora de madrugada
ou pegar no carro levava pra lá ele
sorri piano de bicicleta mas é
importante que exista a tecnologia a
gente sempre teve esse medo que a
tecnologia sair do controle e nos matar
isso nunca aconteceu segundo medo que a
gente tem que os robôs nos matem porque
eles vão nos matar né
se o chip chegou a capacidade cerebral
humano e depois evoluiu e eles fizeram o
dobro de processamento em 18 meses eles
são mais inteligentes que a gente vamos
matar velho quanto mais inteligente eu
sou - eu quero matar as pessoas
não é inteligente você é mas prova que
serve é esse robô não ser legal brother
e roubou um tipo plantar umas flores vão
regar as plantinhas alimentam uns
passarinhos a que você bota legal eles
vão resolver o problema do senador
aquecimento solar entendo eles vão
arrumar
sei lá o comerciante ricardo estado
islâmico diz o ditado não beleza mas não
sou muito inteligente tudo certo é que o
terceiro medo que a gente tem que os
robôs roubo em nosso trabalho e sempre
que a gente tem esse medo de que robôs
hall bem o nosso trabalho
a gente esquece que a gente odeia o
nosso trabalho velho saca tipo esses
taxistas apavorado com o ver
eu nunca vítima um taxista caiu
amo a minha profissão eles é um dinheiro
que eles ganham por mesclar o emprego
dele tudo mas estou com medo que a
tecnologia tinha emprego desde ok mas
ninguém tipo uma ser taxista tá ligado
como agente preenchido excel dia todo e
dizendo assim eu não quero que o robô
pede um emprego um ano é bom é isso que
a gente vai fazer
já peguei esse roubo brothers e vamos
dar toda a parte chata pra ele fazer
taka ele tem tipo brother não são
preenchidos excel e pra mim mas neta
velhos a cor à fala com o chefe da
reunião de segunda feira de manhã
contigo eles vão fazer tudo pra gente
sacou essa preocupação de perder o
emprego é o príncipe persa uma
preocupação super besta é porque ocupou
é automatizar tudo como aconteceu na
revolução industrial eu não quero ser
modista eu não quero começar a quebrar
as máquinas dizer e vão roubar um
emprego landell eles vão pegar parte
mais chata do meu emprego e que a gente
vai fazer a gente vai fazer o que a
gente faz melhor
a gente vai ser criativo a gente vai
criar a gente curte criar a gente sente
humano quando a gente cria alguma coisa
a gente vai pintar a gente vai ser
pintor
a gente vai querer aplicativo bonito
design bonito para abrilhantar a nossa
mão o que mata e vai viajar para frança
tinha uma foto engraçada saca a gente
vai criar novas indústrias indústrias
que não existiam até bem pouco tempo
porque a gente automatize algumas coisas
a gente pode criar indústrias como
turismo que não existia há pouco tempo
um sei lá o drive through e os campi
kits por bem esse tipo de criação só é
possível porque a gente automatizou
alguma coisa então sobre o tempo ea
gente agora cria uma via gastronômica
por mês em coqueiros no estudo por mês
até onde você olha e gourmet humanos
basicamente criança
e aí eu queria dar umas dicas para você
sobre criação como vocês sabem trabalhar
numa rádio mata atlântica a gente
desenvolveu com os métodos nesses dez
anos de comunicação jovem pra justamente
conseguir fazer com que a criatividade
seja um método e não seja alguma coisa
que deus deu pra você porque a gente tem
basicamente essa é esse mito de que
algumas pessoas são criativas e outras
pessoas não são criativas e eu não
acredito nisso eu acredito que todo
mundo criativo possa se exercitar um
pouquinho então quando os robôs
o seu o seu trabalho braçal apertar de
botão você vai precisar ser criativo e
essas são algumas dicas para você
primeira dica achar sua musa
todo mundo aqui tem uma musa as pessoas
não sabem mas museu é museu por causa de
musa é um museu num lugar velho mas é um
lugar onde você vai pra se inspirar
assim como um pintor pega uma música
para se inspirar um cara que curte uma
mina e se inspira para escrever uma
música a música é importante no sentido
de que você tem que achar o que é aquilo
que que aquela faísca criativa ou um
bate papo com uma pessoa que se acha
super interessante que toda vez que
conversa com ele você fica tipo mega
criativo ou um barco que gosta de beber
pra caramba ver kaká ok esse tem um
monte de idéias saca ou então um livro
sempre selem um autor ou então um filme
ou então um vídeo no youtube um edital
que quando você assiste aqui você tem um
monte de ideia e e se essas coisas que
eu criativa é sua musa é aquilo que te
faz sentir vivo os robôs não tem isso aí
quando você tem um monte de idéias que
você faz a nota a nota num papel porque
as a maioria delas não acontecem porque
basicamente não a coloque em prática e
basicamente porque a gente esquece
direto tem uma tese eu esqueço e direto
tem umas idéias e noto e toda vez que a
nota é muito tem muito mais chance
aproveite um tombo de chance de zero
para 100% de chances de aquela idéia de
fato acontecer
o google passou a nota tudo e é o que eu
chamo de método do diálogo
o diálogo pode não ser o seu diretor
favorito mas ele entrega um filme por
ano ele é o meu diretor favorito e todo
ano ele entrega um baita filme nos
cinemas
nenhum outro diretor consegue entregar
isso garante não consegue o marcos não
consegue e qual o método de alencar ser
criativo assim anotada
você vai lá no btt senhor vai alinhar na
gaveta ao lado da cama do diálogo vai
ter uma gaveta
você vai olhar gaveta dele teve um monte
de papel com anotações são pela
guardanapos apple linhas de hotel saca
tipo papel almaço todo tipo de papel de
pão sei lá seda de maconha ele anota em
todos os papéis que ele pode as idéias
na hora que ele tem as idéias e não
importa se vai usar ou não ele vai
guardar aquelas desde foi numa gaveta e
aí ele tira
a gaveta quando tem algum momento de
criação joga todas as ideias em cima da
cama e vai juntando pega uma ideia vai
fazendo conexões com 45 idéias e tapam o
filme todo ano ele entrega um filme e
quando está no meio de um roteiro quando
tem um bloqueio criativo que ele faz ele
foca ele vira a noite ele fica focado
naquilo não vem ele relaxa
a gente tem essa mania mala de sempre é
que tem algum problema ou na empresa não
manda então fazer serão virar noites a
que tipo reunião de brainstorm está tudo
uma reunião e diz assim não não vamos
sair daqui sem um nome pra parada é o
pior ambiente para criar qualquer coisa
está criando pressão se tenha um
ambiente de drogas que não são brothers
na real está todo mundo meio que se
disputando e tal a grande sacada é
relaxar é dar uma distanciada do
problema é escute a woody allen faz ele
vai tomar um banho ele vai pensar na
vida ele vai correr no central park e aí
nessa corrida de relaxamento esse
distanciamento ele consegue achar uma
solução para um bloqueio por um momento
de bloqueio criativo que ele tem lá no
meio do roteiro e se você parar para
pensar
os grandes pensadores da história estava
em um momento de relaxamento quando
tiveram grande sacada olha o nosso
brother a sec nilton maconheiro que nem
vocês debaixo da árvore cortina vida
mano quando cai uma sã e kaká malandro
gravidade boys é o arquimedes velho
quando descobriu a teoria dos fluidos
onde ele estava em uma banheira broa de
relaxando não focando não virando noite
fazendo serão e comendo pizza de
madrugada ele estava os cantos
distanciamento do problema isso ajuda a
gente enxergar melhor o problema velho e
nos num sei lá os escritórios a gente
não consegue perceber isso
mas lá onde a gente tava a gente pode se
manter mais criativo de manhã então você
deixa uma idéia na parede a nota na
parede de manhã ser mais criativo de
madrugada a nota de madrugada nem o dia
você sabe meu a sua país e criativa sua
museu surgiu então vai surfar não
precisa vir trabalhar depois manda
idéias e assim que é cada pessoa tem o
seu tempo cada pessoa tem a sua musa eu
só peço para que a nota
só peço para que quando encontra um
momento de bloqueio criativo relaxem
velho tem um distanciamento
eu gosto de dar o exemplo do que the
crush quem é que joga em creche
eu só faço sei lá 784 em creche está
ligado é jogo pra [ __ ] o tempo todo
assim odeia quando me ligam porque
interrompe o jogo do que bush não é
desagradável eu estou julgando que the
clash velho e não consigo passar uma
fase 2 717 pois não consigo passar
aquela fase é e às vezes acontece você
que joga em flash que acontece com você
de vez em quando você está jogando não
consegue passar aquela coisa alguém te
liga vai ter que resolver uma coisa
celular ou celular e se resolve essa
coisa quando você volta daquela fase a
solução esse distanciamento ajuda do seu
cérebro a respirar e no momento se volta
a jogar sem ele perceber a solução ali
era só fazer esse movimento e aquela
bolinha ficaria colorida e você pode
pegar aquela bolinha colorida contra
estradinha e fazer com que todos fiquem
estradinhas ea coruja lá embaixo
a idéia é tão legal mas por causa do
distanciamento se conseguiu ver a
solução para aquele problema é por isso
que existem sites como innocentive acho
que todos vocês conhecem são sites de
grandes empresas colocam seus grandes
problemas em qualquer pessoa ao redor do
mundo tomando whisky de cueca na
islândia pode resolver aqueles problemas
muitas vezes porque tem distanciamento
eo melhor de tudo velho não tem o fardo
a culpa ea meta nas costas para resolver
esses problemas e por último lugar em
quarto lugar
confie na comédia a risada ela ajuda a
criar um ambiente de confiança e é por
isso que eu defendo a pessoa que uma
pessoa que é contratado no escritório só
para rir da piada de todo mundo que você
faz a eu sou secretário está e você é o
gerente não sei que não vai ser disse
pra eu sou a pessoa que ri sua pessoa
que rir no escritório velho é tão
importante como gerente de de inovação é
tão importante quando o cara da ati uma
pessoa que ri ela chega às nove da manhã
falou tá ela dá risada melhor a sua vida
na zona de histórias se ter uma idéia
ela começa a rir se acha incrível aquilo
que não falava com seu pai há 15 anos
ele o seu pai pai eu te amo
embora sua vida familiar melhora sua
vida em família melhor a sua vida social
melhor a sua vida no escritório e fica
mais criativo por causa da pessoa que ri
meu maior medo velho não é que os robôs
vão dominar o mundo
meu maior medo e toda energia que o
gasto não é pra que uma máquina sem alma
hobby um trabalho da minha filha ou não
é pra lutar contra essas esses robôs que
provavelmente vão roubar o emprego dela
o meu maior medo é a minha luta energia
é pra que a gente não via um robô
muito obrigado